I have some kind of infection in my body that I cannot get rid of.
I can't fix the structural wall of my chest back.
I believe it originated in the stomach, possibly H. Pylora,
Xantivionic resistant affects my brain,
eyesight, muscles, all my joints.
I'm unable to get IV antibiotic therapy.
So I don't know where the question is of that,
except maybe what could this possibly be?
So when you have an antibiotic-resistant infection,
it certainly could be a bacteria
that you're just not getting the right antibiotic.
So getting whatever affected area cultured
contested for what is going to be the best antibiotic
if it is a bacteria is the right thing to do
if you have a chronic infection.
The other thing, possibility is that it's not a bacteria.
So if it's not a bacteria,
then antibiotics aren't going to help at all.
So if you're trying to take care of some chronic viral infection
with an antibiotic, it's not going to work.
Chronic infections are real.
You can't have bacteria, viruses, parasites, different fungi
that are resistant to your immune system's ability to kill them
for all sorts of different reasons.
On our chronic Lyme course, I go into details
on the different reasons that that happens.
These different organisms have the ability to hide
within your normal microbiota.
They have the ability to create walls around them
so that your immune system can't kill it.
And worse, they have the ability,
sometimes to go intracellular.
So if they go inside of a cell,
then your immune system isn't going to kill
something your immune system doesn't go inside the cell.
So if they're hiding within cells and they're replicating
and they're going outside of cells and making you sick
and that operation continues,
yeah, you could have what's called a chronic infection.
So it could be bacterial, it could be viral.
There's tests that you could do to find out.
There is, if you know what's a pathogen,
running a pathogen antibody array,
which is a Cyrex array 12, I think it is,
can be helpful to know what you're dealing with.
I will say that there's people that think
that they may have a chronic pathogen,
but really they just have a chronic autoimmune disease
that has yet to be diagnosed.
So getting proper workup is really important.
Running antibody tests for self tissue is important
to just rule things out because it may not,
you may not have the presence of a pathogen anymore.
You're just getting these chronic symptoms
because of an autoimmune issue.
Especially when you talk about things that you mentioned here,
it affects my brain, my eyesight, muscles, and all my joints,
you start thinking of possibly a systemic autoimmune disease
or an autoimmune disease that's affecting your brain.
So a neural tissue.
So if you have an autoimmune disease,
it's affecting your neural tissue.
You have an inflammation that's chronic in your brain
and it can affect basically anywhere in your body then.
So if you get these weird symptoms that move around,
that's very common.
So those are the kind of things that I would do
instead of trying to get IV antibiotics.
I would figure out what is actually causing my problem.
I've seen people that were convinced that they had chronic Lyme
and that the infection was still present
and they went on IV antibiotics
and it just destroyed their gut and made them much worse
and didn't leave them in a better state.
When in fact, their issues worked,
they did have chronic Lyme,
but their issues worked that they had a current infectious organism.
They didn't have the presence of a current infectious organism.
They had the effects of what that organism did,
which would left their body in a state
where they had created antibodies against self tissue.
So they had an autoimmune disease never diagnosed
and that was what was giving them their majority of their symptoms.
So the going on the IV antibiotics just made their problems
or so they simply don't want that.
So getting a proper workup would be the right thing in a order.
However, if you do want to work with us,
if you want to work with somebody local
and find a local functional medicine doctor,
if you want to work with us,
you can certainly do so go on codersclinic.com.
Again, if you can schedule now,
you'd schedule if you've ever had an appointment with me
for you'd schedule with what's called a case review.
So case review is your initial review with us
and that will be with me on the phone
and we'll talk about your case
and I'll give you some insight hopefully.
And point to the right to our actual least based upon my opinion.
So that may be something that everybody's looking for.